Caption: all right welcome to my talk about how
Caption: to design a prize draw randomizer
Caption: without bugs
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um thank you all so much for having me
Caption: um i really really appreciate the
Caption: opportunity to come up and speak to you
Caption: all
Caption: a big thank you as well to all of our
Caption: amazing sponsors um and also the ddd
Caption: team who make this all possible
Caption: and i'd also like to acknowledge the
Caption: traditional custodians of the land upon
Caption: which we meet um so my name's camille um
Caption: and today i want to take you through
Caption: take you on a little journey which is
Caption: the journey of your career
Caption: if i asked you all now to take a moment
Caption: and think about how your career's gone
Caption: what would you think about
Caption: you might be thinking about
Caption: what skills have i learnt that i didn't
Caption: know before
Caption: how much has my salary increased since i
Caption: started and was i able to provide for my
Caption: loved ones and my lifestyle
Caption: how many promotions did i have
Caption: did i get recognized for my
Caption: contributions
Caption: what projects have i worked on and how
Caption: have i changed the world
Caption: did i end up where i wanted to be
Caption: and am i doing what i want to do in life
Caption: these are all very valuable things to
Caption: reflect on and things that are important
Caption: in in our lives
Caption: but i noticed something when reflecting
Caption: upon this question myself
Caption: it isn't often that we stop to think
Caption: about how our careers have changed us as
Caption: people
Caption: and also how we've changed other
Caption: people's lives
Caption: we don't often think about the
Caption: uniqueness of our full selves and our
Caption: experiences and what these are brought
Caption: to the table
Caption: now being somewhat of a geek and a game
Caption: developer i found it easier to
Caption: understand this when i visualized career
Caption: journeys like video games
Caption: so what we bring to our careers starts
Caption: well before we even get our very first
Caption: job
Caption: we start off with from birth some things
Caption: that have been
Caption: out of your control
Caption: someone's rolled the random selection
Caption: and chosen for you your genetics
Caption: your family background
Caption: and your country or your culture
Caption: and these factors can have a big impact
Caption: on what our interests traits
Caption: values and morals will be
Caption: a little bit of nature and a little bit
Caption: of nurture
Caption: i'll call these things our initial stats
Caption: maybe you grew up in a family of
Caption: technically minded people who taught you
Caption: from a young age things like maths and
Caption: chemistry and even programming and had
Caption: grand expectations of you
Caption: or maybe you grew up in a family full of
Caption: sporty-minded people where you were the
Caption: black sheep
Caption: clinging to your nintendo and your crt
Caption: monitor much to the dismay of your
Caption: family
Caption: or maybe you had nothing to do with
Caption: technology until much later in life
Caption: factors such as those and how we respond
Caption: to them have an impact on stats like our
Caption: confidence our independence
Caption: our willpower and ability to overcome
Caption: challenge
Caption: how we deal with pressure
Caption: and our range of complementary or world
Caption: knowledge
Caption: and they can also instill in us values
Caption: of what we find important in life
Caption: now we progress through our main
Caption: storyline with these stats and this
Caption: involves a typical
Caption: childhood school high school and
Caption: university before we get to work
Caption: there's also a whole bunch of little
Caption: side quests that pop up and have an
Caption: effect on you whether you realize it or
Caption: not
Caption: those are things like that time you move
Caption: schools that time you stood up to a
Caption: bully that time you won a scholarship or
Caption: that time you failed an exam
Caption: all of these can have a profound effect
Caption: on shaping up these stats that
Caption: collectively make up who you are
Caption: and then finally we enter the kingdom of
Caption: work
Caption: now i just want to examine our stats a
Caption: bit here because i feel like this is
Caption: where people are missing out on some
Caption: things
Caption: society tends to have some stereotypic
Caption: stereotypical views about what makes
Caption: people successful in their careers
Caption: traits such as confident intelligent
Caption: hard-working
Caption: well-spoken collaborative and focused
Caption: a lot of people i've met focus on these
Caption: sorts of things and think they're
Caption: lacking
Caption: they lack the confidence needed to climb
Caption: up the ladder
Caption: or they aren't as smart as everyone else
Caption: in the room
Caption: or they like working on their own
Caption: i remember interviewing multiple people
Caption: for a technical role a few years back
Caption: it was a role that required some
Caption: advanced mathematics skills for robotics
Caption: kinematics
Caption: and we interviewed some people who had
Caption: phds and advanced degrees in maths very
Caption: very impressive on paper
Caption: we presented them with a fairly basic
Caption: trigonometry challenge to start it's my
Caption: trigosaurus i'm very proud of that
Caption: um it was quite interesting to see the
Caption: people who had some people who had the
Caption: advanced degrees and phds going about
Caption: the challenge in a very complicated way
Caption: and quite confidently i might add
Caption: and then eventually becoming defeated
Caption: when they realized they didn't know how
Caption: to do it
Caption: on the flip side you had people who had
Caption: much less academic experience or were
Caption: less confident and had only high school
Caption: mathematics skills who were able to
Caption: complete the challenge successfully
Caption: we also had people who completed it
Caption: successfully in simply saying
Caption: i don't know the equation to this but
Caption: this is what i do
Caption: it was a case of very educated people
Caption: over complicating something that was
Caption: actually quite simple and perhaps their
Caption: exposure to complicated questions
Caption: prompted them to assume the answer was
Caption: similarly complicated
Caption: definitely in some situations you
Caption: absolutely do need those complicated
Caption: solutions but in this example high
Caption: academic knowledge didn't guarantee
Caption: real-world success while a simpler view
Caption: of the world mixed with things like
Caption: calmness under pressure or critical
Caption: thinking was effective
Caption: there are often times many ways to
Caption: achieve an outcome
Caption: confidence is a big one that people
Caption: dislike about themselves
Caption: when preparing this presentation i asked
Caption: a bunch of people that i know about
Caption: their best and worst work-related traits
Caption: and this was by far the most popular um
Caption: disliked trait that people had of
Caption: themselves
Caption: funnily enough it was mentioned by
Caption: someone who i was actually going to use
Caption: as an example
Caption: she said she doesn't have enough
Caption: confidence and likes to validate
Caption: things i worked with this person for
Caption: about a year and a half
Caption: and she similar to me is more of an
Caption: anxious worrisome person
Caption: we worked in a very physically high risk
Caption: environment and understandably that made
Caption: us both even more stressed out as
Caption: worrisome people
Caption: some people wanted to steam ahead and
Caption: a handful like her tried to keep up with
Caption: the pace while focusing on things like
Caption: doing things safely on ensuring our code
Caption: had tests double and triple and
Caption: quadruple checking everything and
Caption: looking out for everyone
Caption: she's someone who would always think of
Caption: worst case scenarios and would try to
Caption: mitigate them
Caption: but the fact that she overthinks
Caption: sometimes and needs to validate
Caption: everything can be so valuable they are
Caption: massive strengths
Caption: it not only kept us physically safer but
Caption: it also made us made me feel more
Caption: relaxed knowing that she was around
Caption: knowing that there was someone there who
Caption: was that observant and cautious made me
Caption: feel safer
Caption: so while we need to not let those kind
Caption: of things affect our lives in negative
Caption: ways this points out something very
Caption: advantageous about you
Caption: not everyone is capable of that extent
Caption: of empathy awareness of risks and
Caption: urgency to resolve issues
Caption: people who don't have confidence levels
Caption: at 100 are extremely valuable in other
Caption: ways
Caption: sometimes actually because they don't
Caption: have 100 points of confidence and
Caption: shouldn't feel like they're lacking
Caption: you have the same thing with company
Caption: direction
Caption: there will always be some people who
Caption: have big visions and say things like yes
Caption: yes absolutely we can do that for you in
Caption: two months
Caption: and then you'll have other people who
Caption: would shudder and say the same thing
Caption: needs to be scoped out thoroughly and
Caption: estimated and they'll probably come back
Caption: with a timeline more like four years
Caption: i know you probably all have stories
Caption: similar to that one um
Caption: we need both those people
Caption: we need people who are risk takers who
Caption: are enthusiastic and like to please
Caption: and we need people who are grounded who
Caption: are risk averse and are more cautious
Caption: this is a fantastic combination of
Caption: different people who have different
Caption: strengths
Caption: so if we examine again our stats we
Caption: should realize that these stereotypical
Caption: ones are barely scratching the surface
Caption: of what makes people successful
Caption: accomplished and valuable
Caption: there are a whole lot more things that
Caption: you offer and some of those are actually
Caption: things you think are weaknesses
Caption: so how can you reflect on this
Caption: think about each thing that you've ever
Caption: thought was your weakness
Caption: and then ask yourself
Caption: if a person like this this joined my
Caption: team what would i get them to work on
Caption: and why
Caption: because sometimes i find it's much
Caption: easier to think rationally when it's
Caption: less personal for you
Caption: for me i always used to think to myself
Caption: wow my memory is really poor i can never
Caption: absorb things that i read about or hear
Caption: about
Caption: i'm anxious and i worry a lot
Caption: i have difficulty focusing in meetings
Caption: and miss a lot of what's going on
Caption: i surrounded myself with highly
Caption: intelligent people and always felt very
Caption: inadequate
Caption: how did i even get this far
Caption: and i realized that well maybe those
Caption: things aren't actually the only recipe
Caption: to success
Caption: maybe i have some other stuff going on
Caption: for me
Caption: my memory is poor but i would sometimes
Caption: take great notes to make up for that
Caption: notes which other people needed as well
Caption: it also made me great at learning how to
Caption: teach things simply because which many
Caption: of my fellow human beings need because i
Caption: understood what they'd have difficulty
Caption: with
Caption: i worry a lot and people
Caption: for some reason tend to make me in
Caption: charge of quality assurance for some
Caption: reason because i can be quite pedantic
Caption: about it
Caption: i have difficulty focusing but i like
Caption: when people are concise and to the point
Caption: and it means i filter out things that
Caption: maybe aren't the top priority to me
Caption: right now and focus on things i actually
Caption: do need to know
Caption: it's also because sometimes my brain is
Caption: thinking about a hundred different
Caption: things at once and that in itself is
Caption: hectic but also kind of awesome in a way
Caption: i surround myself with highly
Caption: intelligent people and learn to
Caption: appreciate that if i'm sitting at a
Caption: table with them and i've been there for
Caption: quite a while
Caption: then it probably means i have something
Caption: equivalent to that which i bring to the
Caption: table and that makes me kind of proud
Caption: so i want to surround myself with even
Caption: more impressive people because that
Caption: means i'm leveling up in my own way and
Caption: i can also learn a hell of a lot from
Caption: them
Caption: focusing on what we lack can sometimes
Caption: prompt us into improving ourselves
Caption: but if we forgot forget to focus on what
Caption: we do have and what our strength really
Caption: is in
Caption: then we can really lose out
Caption: your collection of strengths
Caption: is a lot bigger than you realize
Caption: so now that we know about your important
Caption: part in your journey let's look at take
Caption: a look at things around you
Caption: as we've seen it's important to observe
Caption: different types of strengths and this is
Caption: true too when you look at other people
Caption: around you in your career not just
Caption: yourself you don't want the people
Caption: around you to be exactly the same as you
Caption: rather you actually go a lot more when
Caption: they're very different to you
Caption: and companies with the best culture tend
Caption: to recognize this
Caption: so in a game a party is meant to be a
Caption: group of players who have complementary
Caption: skills and work towards a common goal
Caption: you have tanks who are there to protect
Caption: the other players and take most of the
Caption: hits
Caption: you have mages who can deal damage from
Caption: far away
Caption: and you have supporting classes like
Caption: healers who are there to keep everyone
Caption: alive
Caption: these are their strengths and they each
Caption: have different roles to play in the game
Caption: now if you had a party made up of purely
Caption: tanks
Caption: you might tackle some of these um the
Caption: easier challenges pretty quickly but
Caption: you'll probably all end up dying later
Caption: on
Caption: and the same goes for if you had a party
Caption: made up of entirely healers
Caption: you'd probably never die to be fair but
Caption: you probably wouldn't go anywhere very
Caption: quickly
Caption: so a party is meant to have people with
Caption: different strengths so that you can
Caption: cover all the bases and face different
Caption: types of challenges together
Caption: and then in addition to your party you
Caption: can also see people like your managers
Caption: as quest givers
Caption: they give you direction the goals to
Caption: accomplish and resources to do so
Caption: but how do those different types of
Caption: people change you as a person
Caption: because you don't come out of your
Caption: careers with the exact same set of stats
Caption: that you started with
Caption: how about when you're tackling some
Caption: enemies
Caption: so some of your party will be there to
Caption: give you support and some will require
Caption: your support
Caption: each time you provide support to a party
Caption: member you are actually strengthening
Caption: your own stats
Caption: it's not a one-way relationship
Caption: you are increasing your points in
Caption: communication
Caption: mentoring
Caption: and oftentimes your own understanding of
Caption: what you're helping them out with
Caption: how many times have you been asked a
Caption: question by someone and started to
Caption: explain only to realize you didn't
Caption: really know how to explain it that well
Caption: sometimes that's an indication that you
Caption: don't actually know it well enough
Caption: yourself
Caption: or sometimes you'll explain something to
Caption: others and realize you do actually know
Caption: what you're talking about
Caption: sometimes you'll ask them for assistance
Caption: and actually answer your own question in
Caption: the process
Caption: now because everyone's different you
Caption: also learn to adapt in the ways that you
Caption: interact with them that's a plus one to
Caption: your perception and adaptation
Caption: this is especially hard when you have to
Caption: give someone difficult feedback or
Caption: constructive criticism
Caption: you're forced to
Caption: improve your diplomacy and your logic
Caption: to avoid confrontations and the wrong
Caption: message being sent
Caption: empathy is also something that i find
Caption: greatly grows when you work closely in a
Caption: team
Caption: the dunning-kruger effect suggests that
Caption: the more we know the more we realize we
Caption: don't know
Caption: and for some of you it makes you more
Caption: humble
Caption: but it also gives us empathy for our
Caption: fellow party members
Caption: we understand the difficult tasks
Caption: they've been they've been given we see
Caption: the long hours they work
Caption: and understand that maybe their manager
Caption: under-appreciates them
Caption: when we realize how difficult something
Caption: like coding is
Caption: we learn to appreciate everyone who does
Caption: it too
Caption: because what we do it is not easy
Caption: but the most important thing i found out
Caption: about people around me was that they
Caption: taught me who i want to be as a person
Caption: you meet people who inspire you people
Caption: you admire
Caption: and also people who show you who you
Caption: don't want to be
Caption: i appreciated friendly and approachable
Caption: leaders and wanted to be like them one
Caption: day
Caption: i saw many team members who were
Caption: overlooked in terms of the difficulty
Caption: the work they were doing and the effort
Caption: they put in and i always try to remind
Caption: myself to appreciate them
Caption: i realize that things are rarely ever
Caption: the fault of a single person and that
Caption: usually we're all trying to accomplish
Caption: common core goals just in different ways
Caption: not to sabotage one another
Caption: i saw toxic and abusive behavior and i
Caption: realized that after years of being quite
Caption: submissive
Caption: that i was no longer able to tolerate
Caption: that and was able to stand up for others
Caption: i took those interactions with people
Caption: far beyond my workplace and into my
Caption: everyday life
Caption: i realized more about who i wanted to be
Caption: as a person
Caption: so what about them
Caption: as we saw earlier
Caption: working with someone is not a one-way
Caption: relationship
Caption: actions that you take in your career can
Caption: change other people's lives too
Caption: you are an important part of their quest
Caption: because every party member is a player
Caption: in their own journey
Caption: each with their own set of stats
Caption: fears and goals
Caption: we want each one of your party to level
Caption: up and accomplish great things and have
Caption: fun doing it
Caption: so what are some things that you do that
Caption: proactively makes other people's lives
Caption: better
Caption: something i found to be a little
Caption: underrated um is fostering good team
Caption: culture
Caption: good culture for me is what makes me
Caption: want to get out of bed in the morning
Caption: and come to work
Caption: we all know we need the money
Caption: but working with people that you get
Caption: along with
Caption: makes it far less of a chore
Caption: so when you make people laugh you
Caption: actually make the work environment more
Caption: relaxed
Caption: when you organize social events make
Caption: friendly banter
Caption: welcome new people and make them feel
Caption: comfortable
Caption: and encourage a collaborative no blame
Caption: environment then this is all part of it
Caption: so are you someone who builds on the
Caption: team's culture
Caption: have you ever gone out of your way to
Caption: help someone with the task that they
Caption: were stressing about
Caption: perhaps they had some tight deadlines or
Caption: they were really unsure about how to do
Caption: something
Caption: i'm sure you had your own tasks to do
Caption: but you still took some time out of your
Caption: day to help them
Caption: and to be honest this can have
Caption: ramifications so much deeper than their
Caption: deliverables being delivered this has an
Caption: effect on their stress levels their
Caption: work-life balance and also their mental
Caption: well-being
Caption: not only have you helped them with their
Caption: actual task you have shown them that
Caption: they are not alone
Caption: they have someone's support
Caption: they are part of your team and you have
Caption: their back
Caption: every time you mentor someone to upskill
Caption: them you are helping to increase their
Caption: overall stats
Caption: you are sharing some of your past
Caption: experience with them and how you
Caption: overcame your challenges as well
Caption: this is often much faster than if they
Caption: went it alone and it's basically a way
Caption: of duplicating your stats and your
Caption: experience and passing it over to them
Caption: and lastly one of the best things i find
Caption: where you can really change people's
Caption: lives is acknowledgement
Caption: now this can take the form of a simple
Caption: sentence when you're thanking them for
Caption: their work or more public forms of
Caption: recognition like shout outs at a team
Caption: meeting or your chat channels
Caption: acknowledgement can be related to the
Caption: work
Caption: or their ability or their attitude or
Caption: the impact that they've had
Caption: and this goes a long way to telling
Caption: people that you see their effort or
Caption: their value and you appreciate it they
Caption: are appreciated
Caption: and there's something beautiful to see
Caption: in the fact that human beings or pixel
Caption: art characters can and do go out of
Caption: their way to improve the lives of others
Caption: and not for any reward
Caption: so always remember
Caption: there's so much more to the people
Caption: around you than the work that you're
Caption: doing together
Caption: because people change you every day and
Caption: you change them too
Caption: so a game is often comprised of multiple
Caption: levels you can picture these like the
Caption: various companies you've worked at
Caption: the various roles you've had projects
Caption: you've worked on or challenges that you
Caption: might not have encountered before
Caption: and just like in a game often these
Caption: levels will become harder as you
Caption: progress through your journey so it can
Caption: become hard to realize just how far
Caption: you've actually come
Caption: here's us at our first level slaying
Caption: tiny dragons and yes that dragon has a
Caption: nappy
Caption: um we start off pretty weak because
Caption: we're pretty new to this so we still
Caption: find it a bit challenging and confusing
Caption: this is pretty much the equivalent of
Caption: learning hello world when you don't know
Caption: a single thing about programming
Caption: and as we get further through the levels
Caption: now we're stronger than we were before
Caption: when we started but the dragons have
Caption: actually gotten bigger too they still
Caption: feel difficult to us
Caption: this trend continues all the way up
Caption: through your journey
Caption: every time you get stronger and progress
Caption: through the levels dragons get bigger so
Caption: it feels just as difficult as when you
Caption: start it off
Caption: and the same goes for your career
Caption: but it makes it hard to realize just how
Caption: far you've come when you all you know is
Caption: that the work still feels hard
Caption: your work might be difficult for you
Caption: every single day and
Caption: especially if you work in software
Caption: development or technology not only is
Caption: the work changing every day but the
Caption: problems are difficult they're not
Caption: routine
Caption: but the dragons must get bigger for you
Caption: to get stronger
Caption: if you consider if you continually gave
Caption: one plus one equations to high school
Caption: students they wouldn't grow
Caption: the problems need to get bigger with
Caption: their skills
Caption: so how can we then appreciate appreciate
Caption: how far we've actually come and what
Caption: we've accomplished
Caption: one of the most satisfying ways i found
Caption: was to look back on old projects that
Caption: i'd worked on and delivered even things
Caption: i made in university
Caption: look at the deliverables themselves your
Caption: notebooks your code
Caption: and you might notice that these old
Caption: projects might look amateurish to you
Caption: now you could do them much better and we
Caption: all know the good old who wrote this oh
Caption: it was me six months ago
Caption: sometimes you'll actually look back on
Caption: old projects and still be proud of them
Caption: because you still think they were good
Caption: work
Caption: and another method is to keep a log of
Caption: all the things you've learned this month
Caption: or this year that you couldn't do before
Caption: and you can now comfortably do
Caption: and for all of these levels remember the
Caption: challenges that you overcame and what
Caption: you gained
Caption: was a brand new type of problem which
Caption: you had to be creative with
Caption: did you deal with difficult customers
Caption: and needed to practice patience
Caption: did you gain determination points for
Caption: pushing through even though it didn't
Caption: get any easier either because you knew
Caption: you had to or because you thought it was
Caption: worth the effort and the difficulty
Caption: or was the level testing your
Caption: self-respect points
Caption: having to say no to unreasonable
Caption: requests having difficult conversations
Caption: or even just knowing when it was right
Caption: to quit
Caption: sometimes you'll learn that these levels
Caption: were actually less about the enemies to
Caption: defeat and more about how you use
Caption: teamwork to beat them
Caption: when i was preparing this presentation i
Caption: was struggling to put my thoughts into
Caption: meaningful words and i was stubborn
Caption: about getting help for a good few days
Caption: when i started getting people's feedback
Caption: not only were they very very useful to
Caption: me but they also made me feel less
Caption: pressure because i felt supported and
Caption: people had my back
Caption: maybe you've had a project that got you
Caption: all excited with the tasks and you
Caption: charged full steam ahead without ever
Caption: getting the end users feedback only to
Caption: discover at the end that it wasn't what
Caption: they wanted or you didn't really have
Caption: their buy-in this teaches you the
Caption: importance of keeping people involved
Caption: understanding the main goal and also
Caption: understanding what different people's
Caption: perspectives are
Caption: are you really helping them
Caption: do you really understand what they need
Caption: and these are not questions exclusive to
Caption: work
Caption: they apply to many things in our society
Caption: and our values and our relationships
Caption: how we respond to challenges that we
Caption: face and what we learn from the end at
Caption: the end in reflection can sometimes be
Caption: far greater than the prize we get at the
Caption: end of their level or what we manage to
Caption: achieve
Caption: now i want to emphasize here there are
Caption: different ways that you can play a game
Caption: and progress through the levels
Caption: so some players will pick a randomized
Caption: character go through the levels really
Caption: quickly and beat the main storyline
Caption: within a day
Caption: some players are thorough and they have
Caption: to complete every single side quest
Caption: available heck some players even watch
Caption: the full cut scenes without skipping
Caption: for me i play games a little differently
Caption: i enjoy games with good mood story and
Caption: aesthetics
Caption: i take my time which is hours actually
Caption: to create my character and customize
Caption: every hair on their beard
Caption: choose a nice armor set that compliments
Caption: my sword exploring the maps taking
Caption: screenshots and building up my
Caption: environment as if i live in it
Caption: i am not one of those fast players
Caption: i take my time
Caption: and so there are many different ways
Caption: that people enjoy their game and the
Caption: same goes for your career
Caption: how you choose to play your career out
Caption: can be totally different to someone
Caption: else's
Caption: there are different ways to play the
Caption: game and each way can be just as
Caption: valuable and enjoyable as another
Caption: so at the end of your career journey
Caption: you'll hopefully come out with the
Caption: following things
Caption: so loot or money
Caption: a number of dragons slayed which is your
Caption: projects and your accomplishments
Caption: higher status in the world
Caption: and new skills
Caption: but it's important to once again reflect
Caption: on something that we often forget
Caption: you
Caption: what did your career give to you as a
Caption: person
Caption: and what did you give to your career
Caption: beyond magic spells and your code and
Caption: your deliverables
Caption: how have you affected the lives of
Caption: others around you on a personal level
Caption: and i lie a bit here this actually isn't
Caption: the end this is something that you can
Caption: reflect on throughout your whole career
Caption: because careers can end and start anew
Caption: and when one journey ends another can
Caption: start so that's why it's important to
Caption: get something out of it that will carry
Caption: on
Caption: it's important to reflect on you every
Caption: now and then because that's something
Caption: that almost more than these other things
Caption: mentioned you can apply to your personal
Caption: life outside your career
Caption: you use your stats with confidence in
Caption: your relationships
Caption: use your stats in problem solving when
Caption: your car breaks down
Caption: use your stats in communication when you
Caption: teach your kids
Caption: and the way that you treat others in the
Caption: workplace has an effect on who they
Caption: become as people too
Caption: you learn to appreciate differences in
Caption: people that you work with and start to
Caption: appreciate differences in people in your
Caption: everyday life
Caption: you learn to appreciate your real and
Caption: many strengths in your career and you
Caption: start to appreciate just how much you
Caption: have to offer this world
Caption: your journey is unique
Caption: as are you
Caption: now tell me
Caption: how has your career gone
Caption: you
Caption: [Applause]